on reste à voisins le bretonneux chaque
année mais tu as as accueille des
groupes dans ses studios d'art d'une
expérience et l'un d'entre eux son style
de l'électro rock à l'origine de frais
rambolitains qui jouent ensemble depuis
dix ans la fête de la musique est leur
première fédérale entendent justement je
pense c'est d'avoir réussi à mélanger
deux styles musicaux entre le rock qui
plus pour toi et l'autre côté l'électro
qui est plus actuel et bélanger
alors il est de style mélangé de style
donc moi qui vais jouer de la guitare
des sonorités un peu un peu rock on va
rajouter derrière de la batterie d'aidés
grosse caisse et de la basse vraiment
électrodes des sonorités électro donc le
mélange fait que c'est plutôt pas mal
on vit des expériences nouvelles tous
les jours avec la musique je trouve cela
enrichissant de d'avancé comme ça et de
découvrir à chaque fois de nouvelles
choses et c'est ça qui nous fait avancer
dans la musique aussi
[Musique]
oui à jane la sauce bipôle we own the
night
[Musique]
wikia flamme non
pradines oversize sophie pillay
et ça
là
[Musique]